hi this is Mario tomorrow's math
tutoring coming to another math video to
help you boost your score in your math
class improve your understanding and
hopefully make learning math a lot less
stressful so what we're going to talk
about in this geometry video is when
you're working with similar solids how
do you find the volume given the surface
area we're gonna look at an example and
I'm going to show you how to work with a
scale factor the ratio of the areas in
the ratio of the volumes in this video
so let's go ahead and jump right into it
here we're given two square pyramid so
you can see the bases are squares their
pyramids this pyramids a little bit
large in this pyramid but let's just say
in this example that they tell us that
the two pyramids are similar what that
means is that the corresponding angles
are congruent but the ratios of the
sides okay and the ratio of the links
are proportional so you know they're the
one figure is proportionally larger it's
not distorted it's not like it's you
know a lot taller than it is wide you
know it's it's scaled okay according to
a certain scale factor and they give us
the two surface areas are 16 and 25 and
what I'm going to do is I'm just gonna
write that as a ratio 16 over 25 now
what you want to pay attention to is
that area is a 2 dimensional right so if
we want to find the scale factor meaning
like the ratio of the side lengths like
that we're gonna have to take the square
root of the ratio of the surface area so
by taking the square root square root of
16 is 4
square root of 25 is 5 now I know that
the ratio of this side length to this
side length okay they're in the ratio of
4 to 5 now if I want to find the ratio
of the volumes remember volume is
actually three dimensional right so it's
like length width height that stays 3d
right it's three dimensional so we have
to take the scale factor which is the
ratio of the one dimensional parts of
the figures and we have to cube that
scale factor to get the ratio of the
three-dimensional component ok the
volume so if we take that 4/5 and we
cube it we get 64 over 125 now we know
the ratio of the volumes they give us
the volume of the smaller pyramid which
is 20 and so I'm going to make a
proportion and say 20 is 2v the volume
of the larger pyramid now how did I know
to put the 20 here and not here well you
can see 64 is smaller than 125
so I'm comparing the small to the large
small to the large and we're making a
proportion so this is what we're going
to solve right here what you want to do
is you want to cross multiply so you
have 64 v equals 20 times 125 and then
you just want to divide both sides by 64
and that's going to give you the volume
of the larger pyramid I'll go to the
calculator we'll figure out real quick
just so you can see what this comes out
to you so it's 20 times 125 all divided
by 64
it looks like it's approximately 39 I'm
just gonna round approximately 39
centimeters cubed okay so you're with me
so far so you want to analyze whether
it's a one dimensional like you're
comparing side lengths or perimeters
okay or circumference --es or if it's
two-dimensional like area or surface
area then it's you know two-dimensional
you want to square that scale factor or
if it's three-dimensional whether it's
volume you know you're comparing you
know a three-dimensional figure to
another three-dimensional figure you
want to take that scale factor and cube
it now the tricky question is really
when they're giving you like the volume
and you want to find the ratio of the
surface areas or the surface area you
want to find the ratio of the volumes
what I recommend doing is figure out
what the scale factor is first and then
you can square that scale factor to find
the ratio of the areas or cube that
scale factor to find the ratio of the
volumes so if you can find the scale
factor that'll make it a lot easier
let's take a look at this chart here if
you know the scale factor is 1 to 2
what's the ratio of the areas one before
right because I'm squaring one that's
one I'm squaring two that's for the
ratio of the areas is one to four what's
the ratio of the volumes
well one to two if I cube those that's
going to be one to eight and I'm writing
it like a ratio with the colon but you
can just as well as write this as a
fraction 1/8 okay now if they give us
the ratio of the surface areas 9 to 16
I'm gonna want to take the square root
okay so square root of 9 is 3 square
root of 16 is 4 the scale factor is 3 to
4 now I can find the ratio of the
volumes by cubing the scale factor
because remember this is one dimensional
two dimensional three dimensional so to
go from one to three I have to cube that
3 cubed is 27 4 cubed is 64
now this one here they give us the ratio
of the volume okay let me make this a
little bit different example to make it
a little bit more interesting say this
is 125 and say that this is maybe like
let's just say it was like 8 so here
what we're gonna do is we're going to
take the cube root ok cube root of 8 is
2 cube root of 125 is 5 so now I have
the ratio of the side lengths okay the
scale factor we can then square that to
get the ratio of the areas that's 4 to
25 so basically you want to figure out
which one they're giving you is it one
two or three dimensional and then you
can work your way back to find the scale
factor and then go ahead and square it
if you want to find the ratio the areas
or cube it if you want to find the ratio
of the volumes so I hope this helped you
to understand how to work with similar
solids a little bit more easily and
effectively subscribe to the channel
check out some of my past videos and I
look forward to seeing the future ones
I'll talk to you soon